[Musica]
allora prima di parlarvi prima voglio
parlarvi di lavoro anzi di alcuni
mestieri esistono una serie di mestieri
che sono così un po sgradevoli per
esempio l'avvocato lo usiamo l'avvocato
quando abbiamo una separazione
oppure ci troviamo di fronte a un reato
il medico di fronte una malattia
per non parlare l'operatore fine
funerario detto anche becchino che
quello che ci servirà più lontane
possibile spera
e poi c'è il giornalista il giornalista
deve essere scomodo e antipatico per
definizione e per quale motivo perché
non deve parteggiare per nessuno neppure
per te bene
io mi chiamo sergio ferraris e faccio il
giornalista
[Applauso]
allora adesso parleremo di clima
il primo dato essenziale il 98,8 mila
400 73 per cento dei climatologi
mondiali dicono che il cambiamento
climatico è di origine umana e su questo
non si discute se usiamo il metodo
scientifico questa è una certezza
d'accordo indiscutibile bene visto che
ho calcolato i quadro decimali
probabilmente visto un po antipatico per
la pedanteria ed è bene che si accorse
d'accordo e adesso passiamo alla notizia
la notizia che non è una buona notizia
perché le buone notizie non sono tiziano
i giornalisti ci occupiamo di cattive
notizie ci occupiamo di incidenti di
cose di questo genere e che stiamo
perdendo la battaglia del sul clima la
stiamo perdendo la battaglia sul clima e
tu mi dirai ferraris non scherzare
si parla solo di clima sui giornali
segreta turisberg c'è steve jobs bellion
i giornali sono pieni di questioni
climatiche
l'europa ha aumentato gli obiettivi sul
clima
eccetera eccetera trovarla ci stai dando
una fec news benissimo qualche dato
allora nel 1971 quasi 50 anni fa
l'energia prodotta sul pianeta da fonti
fossili
era la 86,1 nel 2018 ultimo dato che
avevano disponibile a livello planetario
l'energia prodotta da fonti fossili sul
pianeta era la 80,86 punti di differenza
in 50 anni non stiamo messi bene
da questo punto di vista ancora
nel 1971 emettevamo 14 miliardi di
tonnellate di co2 in atmosfera nel 2018
ne abbiamo messi 34 quasi triplicata la
quantità
abbiamo anche il triplicato il consumo
di energia per cui abbiamo un solo
pianeta a disposizione e il futuro non è
che sia particolarmente invitante perché
al 2050 avremo 10 miliardi di persone
attualmente siamo 7,5 miliardi e questi
25 miliardi vorranno vivere muoversi
vestirsi mangiare come tutti noi e ai
nostri livelli ed è un diritto che
dovranno avere però ciò implica il fatto
che noi dovremmo generare più energia
d'accordo e saremmo legati comunque alle
fonti fossili
vi vedo un po perplesse
scommetto che state pensando ferraris e
se sei venuto a darci un sacco di brutte
notizie cosa ci stai a fare sul palco
avete ragione però mentre la co2 aumenta
il filmato che mediante cui vedete qui
al mie spalle ha uno splendido
documentario di james baylor e ha
registrato il lo scioglimento dei
ghiacciai in tempo reale nel giro di due
o tre anni qualche anno fa gli effetti
climatici sono qui da noi in italia
pensate semplicemente le ondate di
calore
allora io sono nato nel 1960 compiuto 60
anni costarono all'epoca c'erano le
olimpiadi a roma ea roma le ondate di
calore ossia le notti con più di 25
gradi centigradi erano tre nel 2018 sono
state 26 e i famosi climatologi di cui
sopra dicono che nel 2030 saranno 34
questo è andato e di calore e andarvi di
calore state vedendo l'assetto che fanno
sul ghiaccio
allora rivedo decisamente sconfortati
però sono stato chiamato qui per darvi
una nazione una cosa da fare d'accordo
allora vediamo di passare alla seconda
parte questi sono i numeri che non si
possono nascondere d'arresto io faccio
la giornalista sono antipatico questi
sono numeri scientifici per cui ci
stanno
ok cosa possiamo fare
la prima è che comunque dobbiamo
emettere meno co2 possibile d'accordo
con tutti i metodi possibili e anche
impossibili tutto quello che è riuscito
a immaginarti ma la cosa più importante
è che dovete adattarvi la parola
d'ordine e adattamento e non la dice
nessuno tra parentesi
c'è un problemino per adattarvi dovete
conoscere per conoscere dovete
infornarli e per informarvi dovete
leggerci anno ai giornalisti ambientali
sempre un po antipatici con questi dati
d'accordo e quindi mi spiace dirmelo ma
avrete bisogno del sottoscritto e voi vi
chiederete per quale motivo abbiamo
bisogno del sottoscritto
avrete bisogno sottoscritto per
l'appunto per adattarmi vi faccio
qualche esempio avete bisogno di me per
scoprire se la casa dei vostri sogni che
state acquistando verrà allargata in un
prossimo futuro
avrete bisogno di me per capire quali
rinnovabili scegliere da mettere sul
tetto magari per non rimanere senza
energia elettrica durante un black out
che magari accadrà durante il periodo
estivo avrebbe bisogno di me per capire
come non subirli gli effetti degli
eventi estremi che si manifestano anche
in italia
avrete bisogno di me per apprendere
anche come reagisce il vostro corpo alle
ondate di calore e come difenderli
avrete bisogno di me anche per capire
quali studi dovrà fare vostro figlio in
connessione anche con i cambiamenti
climatici
avete bisogno di informazioni e qui c'è
una questione che vi voglio introdurre
ho parlato di figli ho parlato di futuro
però vorrei invitarvi a riflettere su
come pensiamo al futuro in italiano
usiamo il futuro semplice il futuro
anteriore allora futuro anteriore per
fare un esempio è quello che dice tra
dieci anni avrò vinto la battaglia del
clima magari fosse così io me lo auspico
d'accordo ora chi di voi ha pensato a
questioni ambientali negli ultimi tempi
usando il futuro anteriore
alzi la mano non vedo mani alzate
diamo marino mi ero preparato anche ad
un'alternativa qualcuno calmava alzava
la mano dicevo
pensavo peggio no va bene ok è andata
così
[Applauso]
allora chiediamoci perché non pensiamo
usando il futuro anteriore
non pensiamo al futuro usando il futuro
anteriore cioè mettendo in relazione due
cose perché sono due cose da mettere
assieme bisogna superare un ostacolo e
pensare questo ostacolo bisogna fare un
costrutto cui non siamo abituati
bisogna sapere da dove partire dove
arrivare e ancora una volta per sapere
da dove partire da dove arrivare in
fatto di clima
vi serve l'informazione perché mi
dispiace dirvelo vi stavo antipatico a
un pochino sulle palle vero un po di
persona che sono un po sconcertante
propri server
ok avete bisogno di un giornalista per
vedere qual è la bussola cosa quali sono
le posizioni climatiche per orientarvi
all'interno di uno scenario enorme che
di informazioni che avete di cui che
avete a disposizione benissimo avete
bisogno un giornalista
magari studio convinti che vi serve un
giornalista e vi chiederete
ok come lo scelgo un giornalista come
dice ferraris tre regolette tra ok uno
non deve mai parlare in prima persona
deve far parlare i fatti nomi le cose
che pensa d'accordo non le proprie
opinioni
2 deve mettere in relazione cause ed
effetti deve darmi gli strumenti per
capire non un ragionamento precostituito
che io capisco che se arriva un
ragionamento precostituite o e comodo
non lo devo fare io ragionamento ma il
giornalista non ha questo ruolo deve
darvi gli strumenti ok
terza cosa la più importante è che non
deve annoiarvi un giornalista deve farmi
arrivare fino alla fine del racconto
tutto d'un fiato senza interruzione deve
appassionare e adesso visto che sono
stato chiamato a dare un segnale di
azione nei vostri confronti per le
questioni climatiche un consiglio su
come usare l'informazione ambientale
perché l'avete trovata e selezionata
voglia davvero bene o usate una cosa
antica il passaparola
ok e vi voglio fare un racconto sulla
potenza del passaparola sulle questioni
climatiche e ambientali
qualche tempo fa un mio amico mi disse
che doveva cambiare l'automobile e
voleva comprare la nuova allora il
sottoscritto è uno che non ha mai
posseduto in vita sua
un'autovettura nuova tuta usate gli
disse che un'autovettura usata.aveva dei
vantaggi sia ambientali che economici
fate attenzione ho messo assieme
ambiente ed economia ambientali perché
più si allunga la vita di un oggetto
meno co2 in produzione viene
praticamente riprodotta un'automobile
per essere prodotta e vengono ammesse
5.000 tonnellate di co2 d'accordo se
l'automobile 27 anni come vorrebbero le
case automobilistiche voi avrete
un'emissione di 720 tonnellate ogni anno
se questa automobile era fatte vivere di
più tipo 15 anni
l'emissione annuale diventa 330 l'anno
oltretutto vi sia il mio amico guarda
che la palin 60 per cento in meno
non è una banalità bene c'era un piccolo
problema il mio amico mi disse ma quante
sono 5 mila tonnellate di co2 perché usa
un'unità di misura che per me era
scontata ma per lui no
allora io ho fatto un attimo di calcoli
per farglielo capire
e gli ho detto quanta co2 e mette la tua
macchina ora abbiamo fatto i calcoli 130
g km bene se tu allunghi la vita 15 anni
di un'autovettura che già ne ha otto
risparmi 2640 tonnellate di co2 che sono
15 milioni di chilometri
altra cifra un po astratta sulla quale
tornerò tra un attimo ci siamo messi a
parlare poi l'altro qualche settimana
dopo l'incontro il mio amico che mi
disse la prima cosa che mi hanno detto
entusiasmo mi hai con
ho comprato un autovettura usata di sei
anni ma ti assicuro la farò arrivare a
ecco io che sono faccio il giornalista
che faccio articoli e non so chi di
legge
non so che reazioni hanno le persone che
leggono i miei articoli cose di questo
tipo mi son reso conto con questo
passaparola diretto con un mio lettore
un mio ascoltatore della potenza del
passaparola e mi sono reso conto anche
che noi giornalisti non siamo niente
senza di voi detto tra parentesi 15
milioni di chilometri sono quasi venti
volte l'andata e ritorno tra la terra e
la luna non sono uno scherzo d'accordo
adesso che mi ha detto terra luna 20
volte forse mi rendete conto di della
distanza che rappresentano però mi sono
reso conto che il mio lavoro senza di
voi non è nulla per cui se voi avete
bisogno di noi per affrontare
l'adattamento noi giornalisti abbiamo
bisogno di voi
se vogliamo vincere sul serio la sfida
climatica di cosa abbiamo bisogno
abbiamo bisogno di un lettore che prende
il nostro articolo se lo metta sotto
braccio uscendo e se lo porti al bar e
lo faccia vedere agli amici abbiamo
bisogno di lettori che lo condividano
sui social e magari anche commentandolo
aspramente e magari che ci incalzino
quando vedono qualche errore perché
magari potrebbe aver fatto male un
calcolo sulla co2 è cosa di questo tipo
insomma voi avete bisogno di noi e noi
giornalisti abbiamo bisogno di voi per
vincere la battaglia del clima
allora potremmo anche andare a cena e vi
darò informazioni però sappiate che
saranno comunque scomode e che risolverò
comunque antipatico grazie
[Applauso]